this is the type of research that Aubrey
does all the time and this is how she's
able to make these incredible Keynotes
that you guys have seen so check this
out this is all manual analog this isn't
digital what are we seeing here so when
research began in my life to find the
truth about where the world kind of is
going why we have so much Devastation
and problems in the world I did all this
I did all the research online and I
wrote it this is probably the fifth time
that I wrote it it was a big long white
board that I had at first and I kept
running out of space and so I had to get
smaller and smaller and smaller and keep
adding more branches onto this web and
so I decided finally that I'd come to
the end of everything that I knew and it
was a mess on the Whiteboard and I came
to this board that I found from one of
my old um projects from like fourth
grade and I pulled everything off of it
and then I rewrote everything on it so
this is basically like uh a network of
all the occult things that happen in our
world how they're all interconnected yes
where they came from okay so and a lot
of my presentations are stemming from
this because it all starts with the same
place so if we begin here as I usually
do it starts with Noah's sons you had
them get on the ark you had ham Shem and
japheth his sons then we want to focus
on ham because ham was the one who had
this unfortunate love of perversion when
he saw Noah uncovered when he was uh
drunk yeah and the other two sons
honored Noah by not even looking but
putting the robe over him which just
beli that that was more than just seeing
his dad naked he that's what I mean it
was like an excitement it was like he
liked what he saw they say so ham seemed
to have this perversion in him and his
son named Kush then had his son named
Nimrod and and that's where we get
Babylon he was the ruler of Babylon the
god of caldian
mysteries and Father and
Son together Kush and Nimrod it says
this in the Bible right here Genesis 10
verse
1 um and 6 11 ver 1-4 together they plan
and commence to build the Tower of Babel
AKA Babylon it says come let us build
ourselves a city with a tower that
reaches to the heavens so we may make a
name for
ourselves they here's my note they
wanted to be their own Gods doing as
they pleased oh do what thou
wil so if we go down I believe it's
here no sorry I need to go around to
here so God confused the languages right
after that and he called it Babel
meaning confusion in Genesis 911 so
people disperse and Nimrod becomes angry
at God for stopping everything
and he marries his mother
samiramis that's where the Bible doesn't
tell you what happens next you have to
dig into history to figure this out so
always take history biology or nature
and God's word and you can put it
together and they all confirm each other
amen quite honestly and so incest was
used to unite the new false religious
system so here's where we have the
Trinity that comes in as well um he made
Sun worship
um that's right there which means Sunday
was always venerated yeah and celebrated
it was focused on human sacrifice
meaning mostly children and babies but
adults as
well and due to such evil practices Shem
kills Nimrod as an
example he was really honored by God
actually from doing that because it was
holy he was the one that was a mighty
Hunter unto the Lord right no that was
Nimrod Nimrod I thought that's what
talking when you're called a mighty
Hunter before the Lord just like Cain
was yeah and Nimrod was you're actually
saying I am mighty before God I don't
need you oh okay so who are you talking
about this is Shem his cousin I'm sorry
his uncle so this is actually Noah's son
Shem his uncle that kills him because it
was righteous to do so he had founded
this terrible occult um religion and he
kills that guy so it's air Miss now
remember smus is nimrod's Mother and now
his wife wow she take out the followers
and made a false religion further out of
it by saying that
Nimrod um where do I claim to go next um
that
Nimrod was dead but they are all afraid
so all the worshippers are afraid to
practice so the worship ceases they go
underground yeah and Samir must discover
she's
pregnant so she claims
that she's going to cloak it in a new
form to get people to do it again and
again which means I didn't write that
very well but it means she's going to
claim that this child is now the
reincarnate Sun God Son Of The Sun God
so she names Nimrod the sun god herself
the moon goddess and tamuz which is
going to be their
son the god of gods basically wow um her
God was to CLA her idea was to claim
that when Nimrod died he went up to the
Sun the son impregnated her with the
child which was actually Nimrod
reincarnate as the sun god thus deifying
Nimrod herself and the child as Gods so
that's really where yeah this Trinity
comes
from but Satan worship had to be done in
secret so they pushed
underground it was pushed underground by
samiramis because of many who still
believed in the true God of Noah so
there they're afraid for their lives and
so they go underground and this is where
secret societies are born they actually
had Caverns they had caves they had
these holes and Hills that they made to
with lots of marble you know if you know
that they're they always love their um
carved rock yeah everything's really
elaborate that's where we also get the
Masons because these were the Mason
Freemasons if you will they are really
good at at building brick things and
rock things so they would be the first
people to usually create these cult
caverns of worship that the secret
societies um met in so they were a
mystery religion that began where Satan
worship was worshiped in secret
Mysteries lives deception and mystery of
iniquity the occult and illusion was
their
practice so when we go from
there man this is so much yeah um Nimrod
was the son God samiramis the moon
goddess the child mostly is just named
tamuz but he's also a God then we have
bell and Lil Jupiter cathic Spirits he
is known as all these things Bale balum
B all symbolized by the sun Allah Hadad
Ashu the world begins to
assimilate and she becomes known as the
Queen of Heaven her symbol's always the
Moon aarte asth and that's why in the
cath in the Catholic church we see the
quote unquote Queen of Heaven who they
say is Mary and she's standing on the
moon that's right but that's amazing
that you mention that because right here
it says having set up all of this she
sets up confessionals where people must
confess sins to her ordained priests
proclaiming her and her priests are the
only
alone oh only and alone understood the
mysteries of God and that they were the
only way possible to God
wow they also had to take secret Oaths
steeped in Magic deception and illusion
that is the Catholic church in a
nutshell right there right so you have
the overthrow of Babylon by the mes and
Persians and all of the followers of
Baal which had gone underground all the
secret societies and everybody go to the
island of Alexandria in
pergamos I said that right right yeah
pergamus pergamus which became the seed
of Satan you can look this up you can
find it then spreading again later by
the time of Christ to Rome the final
seat of
Satan so they went into hiding in
Alexandria where they
became Master's um Magis if you will um
ascended masters all of them really
practiced their crafts of levitation
meditation um demonic channeling
everything that we have today sacrifice
torture they all became Masters at it
they just practiced and practiced on the
AL island of Alexandria where they would
actually Chronicle everything in their
Library of Alexandria for other people
to
use and a lot of oul people are still
trying to find bits and pieces of the
books and knowledge of the island of
Alexandria because they want to get back
to those days of that knowledge of the
Mysteries of the occult so anyway these
are all the different names in Phoenicia
it went uh tamuz became known as oh he
was I'm sorry so in Phoenicia Nimrod was
known as tamuz
ironically and Horus in Egypt it was
Osiris in Greece it was Aeros in Rome it
was Cupid or the boy Jupiter in China or
Asia it was Dias I don't know how to say
that exactly IND India is wara Babylon
the winged one bakus Centaur Orion pan
so I'm not going to go through all of
this but you can just see it there
hopefully and she became known as asth
estarte Isis Aphrodite or Irene V Venus
or Fortuna shingu and her child or cbel
iy Ishtar Ria Diana okay so you can go
down and you can find all of those but
then I kind of took it and I was like
why as I have a note here why are they
all the same male or female it doesn't
matter they become there's a duality of
genders that
happens so I started a nonbinary or
gender fluid that's right it's nothing
new and you can see that I started um
trying to understand where LGBT came
from and that was from Anana I found out
the Queen of Heaven so again it's her
you can tie it right back to smeir miss
the Queen of Heaven and sybel as you've
seen hopefully you've seen my other
presentations on androgyny and Nana is
the same as cbel or aarte or all the
different I've given in the androgyny
presentation it's the same
goddesses they're just called something
a little bit different because of the
way when these names and practices would
spread to different cultures and um
places of the world they would change
the name a little bit because mainly
they couldn't say the words in their
language so Isis it was like I see like
you saw here well we still have that
today you know somebody named Michael
like myself I'll be called mguel yeah or
Miguel or something Michelle and France
that's right so anyway going forward I
finally um came to more understanding on
this topic like I said that I presented
in my androgyny presentation and then I
was just getting upset and quite
honestly I went through a lot of
depression going through this I this
took two whole days to research and set
up and rewrite and rewrite and rewrite
my parents watched me in this like stoop
of just depression and crying and um
finding out where all this comes from so
war and killing all matters of blood
sacrifice human animal or other are made
to conjure Elemental forces that
collectively relate to satanic baffet
underworld Realms used by satanists
witches Voodoo and Islam using killing
Andor drugs to allow one's body to be
possessed by spirits to give control get
addicted feeding into Satan's power they
use sacrifices and killing to to cause
disassociation trauma and abuse to
develop split personalities wow and
perverse coping mechanisms such as
sociopaths and Psychopaths opening doors
to being used by Satan further this is
MK Ultra this is what they do to the
celebrities they split their fragment
their personality that's right so I did
this for each problem that at the time
came to my mind drinking it comes from
dionis Shiva and Odin those are the main
Gods that you would find drinking under
and it's part of the faith for pagans to
do because it honors the gods and Pagan
ancestors okay so in the pagans they
emphasize responsibility of drinking in
mediation or moderation balance between
enough good and evil harmony with both
to praise the gods but be responsible
member of society so we see that in our
society why are they
promoting moderation just like the
pagans did way back when to have chaos
chos and order in a balanced mixture put
together yeah just so anybody knows uh
we will be covering topics about
drinking smoking marijuana all these
things that intoxicates your mind the
Bible over and over says be sober for
Satan is like a roaring lion seeking
whom he can Devour the Bible wants us to
be sober and people bring up these
verses like will Jesus turn water into
wine and a little wine for the stomach
you look at the original context that is
actually talking about grape juice it's
talking about new Wine Not fermented
Wine Not death um when you think of what
what wine is what fermented wine is it
is a grape that's rotting and now you
have uh the the feces of why can't I
think of the word the uh the yeast or
the amibas or whatever it's it's
actually their fecal matter that make it
ferment and that becomes what
intoxicates your mind Satan's trying to
intoxicate this he's trying to keep us
from being able to communicate with God
mhm and anytime we're drunk or Med
Medicated by TV movies games all those
things that is interfering with our
connection to God and that's where Satan
wants us
MH so we'll just finish this real quick
it's to evoke drinking is also to evoke
Spirits in ritual ceremonial practices
that's really call alcohol Spirits
that's yeah exactly right so going back
to LGBT I had more I had to write so
it's down here bisexual and gender
neutrality transgender he was found in
Mesopotamia in nature so can you believe
that he was in Mesopotamia first the
ideal Pagan priest is both female and
male by m
mutilation now I know a lot more about
it in my androgeny presentation still
but that's where it began the god an was
androgynous had androgynous Priests of
Mesopotamia same as cbel and Ria
refusing to be just one gender but
possess character and physical ATT of
both man that's our world today and nut
yes so let's go like rape I didn't want
to go into it too far but it actually
has ceremonial practices and rituals
associated with it in religion so Isis
which is in Islam that rape actually
honors the god Hinduism they have it in
there honoring Zeus and Marduk Marduk is
Bale as well so let's just leave it at
that I'm not going to go into it cussing
and profan people have wondered about
that persone was the goddess of this she
was actually called the Mistress of
curses she did this to invoke demons to
be dispersed on one on enemies when
cursed in her
name
okay she it's also used by wiah witches
of Witchcraft pagans and spiritualists
satanists with understanding that they
are honoring and calling upon persone
and other gods when doing so
yeah you think about
um cursing when do you do when do you
cuss when you're angry when they call it
cursing because you're literally placing
a hex you're cursing usually you point
your finger which there's a a bad stigma
with pointing you're not supposed to
point your finger you point and you yell
curses at somebody this isn't something
that you would find in the fruits of the
spirit this isn't something that you
would typically see coming from a
Christian there's a reason why pagans
and uh lost people have filthy mouths
you know and unfortunately that's
actually seeped into the Christian world
I was a Christian for eight and a half
years just cussing pretty much like
anyone else and uh eventually I never
took an initiative to stop cussing I
just got closer to God and and it it
lifted off me so that was awesome right
so pornography even it's a part of all
sexual God practices
see and do bad sexual things or these
mostly naked statues even through
looking at them and then pleasure
yourself basically it's all bail worship
yeah and pedophilia that's the worship
of our duke or molok the Rothchilds and
World Elite that control banking do this
we know this today lot's coming out
right now it is child sex
trafficking blood sacrifices and lots of
blood is said
to open the portal of CERN you guys have
heard of CERN molok and Marduk the CERN
sorry molok and Marduk to take form oh
that's what I mean okay so the portal in
CERN is supposed to be opened so that
molok or Marduk it's both the same God
can take form and bring we can bring him
into this Dimension that's what it's
supposed to be that portal is also said
to be the Ark of baale we have that Arch
and I've seen that I've spoken on that
in my other presentations as well that
that Arch is set up everywhere in the
world there's several of them by
now but and they have that Shiva statue
outside soon
yeah so some actually decided to
specialize in fertility Cults as well
instead of just pedophilia or sex so you
phallic worship a male sex organ deeon
AOS Hermes Odus Atlas Buddhism Shinto
mat these are all um Asian by the way
yam p Neptune Osiris and Min that's
another um huge Asian one where they
have masturbation and caressing the
fondling of a phallic statue at all of
their festivals and women sit on these
as well and you talked about some of
this and and that's right this is all in
um actually the bail worship who is the
Rain Man
presentation so um and then I got a
little bit deeper believe it or not I
went I wanted to know where dirty porn
and dirty
heavy porn and stuff came from like
whipping BDSM yeah so uh specifically
this type men worship included whipping
sexually sex and drunkenness for
Transcendence gagging the female with a
penis and whacking in the face with it
which you see in almost every porn
yeah um you worship the image on your
knees in position to be penetrated from
back from the back for women wow so this
is just again this is probably as deep
and as dirty as I want to get but that's
where all that comes from then you have
yanic worship which is a fe female sex
organ they use the pentagram or the
lotus flower for depictions of this and
teaching the ayous sites so flower to
represent the female organ right yes and
this originally comes from estarte asth
which is mentioned in the Bible by name
all these statues and Groves and um
poles of Ashira which we have M poles
today they're same thing yeah um Ishtar
Diana so it's the same as Bell worship
using ashir or ashir poles as sexual
orgy places on hills in worship to bayor
tamuz or Nimrod bringing back warmer
weather for Easter Sunday this is what
Easter Sunday is if you haven't seen my
presentations on the holidays or who is
the Rain Man or all these things kind of
linking these things together now you
know yeah check that out
um so this was a fertility cult practice
it also reenacts female prostitution the
temples were full of it in honor of
Anana using knives and whips dancing and
frenetically oh dancing frenetically so
kind of freaky like I guess if you want
to put it that way like uh just like
what you see at a stripper doing dancing
on a pole and well there you go you have
the
the pole again was stripping so self
mortification that's shaming the woman
into
submission um like she has no worth okay
we see that in rap actually a lot yeah
so here we have Alchemy and devil and
Witchcraft worship that comes from Venus
deeper penetration they actually use sex
to do this deeper penetration they did
this in the Groves and positions were
part of sensing new levels of devotion
you have this um what's that book The
Kamas Sutra yeah um is all about this
I'm also thinking of aliser Crowley's
Sex Magic and thma and all of that yes
this is used heavily in Hinduism in the
Kundalini in Shiva you have the phus and
yonic worship so now people are doing
both they're putting it together for
practice of worshiping through sexual
rituals pouring milk they actually do
this they pour milk on part of of
rituals along with meditation Stone
image of the it's a oh sorry a lingum
yeah the stone image of phus penetrating
Yanni called a lingum they buy it you
know like they do other idols and they
pour that on top of it to have
fertility and they use meditation
prayers yoga and sexual practices to
achieve Transcendence marijuana is
sometimes involved food sacrifices as we
know we've seen them offered to images
of Shiva Transcendence achieved through
deeper penetration and stretching the
female organs out through positions yeah
called the
Kamasutra wow so that's that's why they
have women do these uh crazy yoga and
bending in different positions and all
that that's right and we have tant uh
tant um masturbation all from that stuff
all right where are we now abortion the
worship of bayor molok we should know
that that they were the statue that
burned a fire a heavy going fire and
they put the baby in into that fire
sometimes on the burning hands of Bale
right so that's where abortion comes
from today I didn't put this on here but
today we already have
that it is abortion it's using you know
abortion to do that instead of fire
right they just um you know now they
wear lab coats and make it look clean
and scientific they make it look like
it's your right actually don't take my
rights away to to abort my child right
so um down
here let's see they used okay this is I
went further anal sex and oral sex we
saw this actually again in my who is the
Rainman presentation but oral sex was at
Bale peor it was a Grove or a a meadow
in which they used to do this on top of
you can see pictures of that in the the
presentation it was god of the moabites
Bale peor is a god of moabites where
they did this obscene sex rituals and
then would kill a
child so
um population
control Bill Gates yeah we do have Bill
Gates I didn't write it but I did look
him up and he was included in that
Freemasons always plan to kill off
people which are deemed unnecessary
because they're not in the elite group
of understanding or banking they call
the useless eat
yes they're in the inner group why they
can they think they can do this is
because they're in the inner group of
bail
worship and they have mysterious ways in
which they don't think you know about or
should know about so they put toxins and
air pollutant birth control and
sterilization biological warfare and
resources and viruses to do that toxins
and air pollutants used to be a
conspiracy theory but now Tennessee has
actually banned kimt trails however you
can do that I'm not sure but it's
actually a law you can look it up yes so
if you look here I covered the hexagram
because I wanted to know all right is
the hexagram
itself a cult basically which the
hexagram is the quote unquote Star of
David that you see all the Christians
flying I stand with
Israel um so symbols used to invoke
demons that's why you say to put a hex
that says hex by the way on others a
truly baffet or cabala symbol MH
um hexagram shape is on top of Saturn
they say from NASA photos so here you
get into Saturn worship which we'll get
we'll jump to in a minute has eye the
storm eye or the alling eye on it they
say it's used in Hinduism yoga Satanism
spiritualism
luciferianism witchcraft Etc originally
from Saturn worship the symbol is given
to denote Jews by Hitler's friend which
was a Roo child even though a manora I
found out was a symbol of the Jews a
true
symbol so TV radio is the seven Branch
candle stand that's right TV radio media
and video games this is covered again in
my other presentation I ran out of space
quite honestly I got too tired of going
into deep dark topics at one time so I
left this open I just said Saturn's
Black Cube I explained that so much more
in my other presentation so go look that
up again it's who is the
Rainman one last thing we mentioned
Saturn worship all of a sudden so now we
have to transition into where we see
this actually one of
nimrod's names and his other name Bale
is the same as
Saturn so Saturn was known as Satur AKA
pan Kronos or cronis sebet an L also
called the unconquerable Sun or stolen
Invictus the title the pope calls
himself true symbol is the bull so
here's other names
again which you can find um but he had
raving and clubbing parties which was
usually called saturnalia this Festival
of saturnalia if you've heard of that
there's a week-long pagan Festival
December 17th through the 23rd basically
we get Christmas from this um according
to Julian the Julian calendar so in our
Gregorian calendar it's December 30th
through January 5th so it really doesn't
matter I know it doesn't make it
coincide with December 25th uh
conclusively but it is they always go
based off of the position of the
equinoxes and solstices so that gives a
little bit of room wiggle room each year
according to the location of those
things so they did gambling orgies rape
and all sexual licenses children were
included in this I hope you know
that only in undergarments that's what
you were allowed to have on
crossdressing dolls representing remains
of human sacrifices that had happened
drinking loud music blood pudding they
would eat blood pudding and to represent
animal and human sacrifice as well this
is um this is Spirit cooking yes there
you
go um the word Gala such as a Met Gala
was used for festivities wow all the
celebrities go to the Met Gala yes this
was basically a combination when you
really get down to it they want you to
worship all the gods because all the
gods truly are Satan that's right so
Pagan worship was a combination of sun
moon stars celestial objects idols and
statues the pantheon of many deities and
the worship of drinking sex and
nature I think I covered it all but
that's everything that's where I mean I
I have this part as well covering some
of the holidays the U logs where they
came from candles tree and
decorations that all came from a Hot
Cross Buns we'll just read this cooked
in and to the Queen of Heaven that
actually comes from the Bible mhm 40
days of weeping became lent Easter the
eggs are symbols of fertility as Pagan
pagans worshiped Easter Sunday and would
go up to the mountain sides early Easter
Sunday to practice sexual practices of
producing new life that was rape and
also orgies
in recreating marriage of deus sorry
deid and Anana as myth would have it
temples of
priestesses of reenacting sexual acts of
Anana were held in worship of deuz so
Temple
prostitution was born in
orgies Valentine's Day came from
honoring Cupid and Venus so let's go
back up to here where we talked about
the ulog candles tree and decorations
crot Cross Buns uh weeping tamu's Easter
Sunday this all com from the cold
season
becoming oh sorry comes annually and
they believed their son God was leaving
observing that gradually the return of
the sun happened on December 25th they
hailed it tamu's
birthday and it became a Papal Chris
Mass Christ Mass yeah which would be on
that day as Christ's birthday so here we
have a counterfeit already happening
the T became the symbol of the Sun and
Sun worship the T was the symbol of Tam
right yes thus human sacrifices to the
sun god offered on the tea letter made
of wood known as the cross became a
thing so this is just where everything
be began for me and since then I've been
adding to my knowledge of what the cross
really symbolizes what we really have
um with the influence of Saturn worship
that comes through all of our media and
TV and like I said transgenderism and
it's basically just gotten a lot wider
from there my knowledge of everything
and how God has overcome all these
things and shown himself to be more
powerful than all of this so we just
thought it would be interesting um I'm
at my childhood home right now and so we
thought we let you guys see
what my beginnings of being a researcher
looks like and what it started
like we just wanted to to give you guys
this little peek of what the research
looks like to do the things that we do
on our Channel there is plenty more to
come we're putting out as much content
as we can just being the two of us we go
on speaking engagements we're at
churches often speaking we are traveling
right now we're in Colorado like she
said we're going to be on a podcast
today for Kenne who used to work for
HGTV so we're out here doing things if
you guys want to help support us you can
do so by uh going to these digital forms
that we have cash app venmo zel PayPal
you can go to our website candid
truth.org you can click the Donate
button you can also check out our merch
we got cool shirts stickers all kinds of
stuff that you can represent you can
wear something cool like a Bible verse
on your shirt and that actually helps us
we get about $5 per shirt that sells and
we just can't thank you guys enough for
your support your love all the comments
that have been coming in we've been
trying to respond to every single one of
them it's amazing we love seeing this
community grow and uh we just want to
thank you and tell you that we love you
and we thank you for your support we
thank you for your patience we're trying
to do everything we can to keep more
content coming out God bless you and we
love you guys